vídeo de poco más de dos minutos a modo
de cortometraje la realización española
de fútbol dio a conocer a las 23
jugadoras que formarán parte del equipo
Nacional de España en el mundial de
Australia y Nueva Zelanda Como podía
esperarse la mejor jugadora del mundo
Alexia putellas ya recuperada de su
lesión que le impidió jugar la Eurocopa
2022 es una de ellas también lo es Jenny
hermoso considerada otra de las mejores
globales y que tampoco pudo jugar la
cita europea del año pasado uno de los
interrogantes era si alguna de las tres
jugadoras preseleccionadas el 12 de
junio que formaban parte del grupo de
las llamadas 15 que en septiembre de
2022 renunciaron a ser convocadas en
protesta por la gestión del
seleccionador Jorge vilda iban a pasar
el corte La respuesta es sí o Aitana y
Mariana caldenté y viajarán a Oceanía
entre las ausencias sorprenden las de
Marta Cardona y Maite oroz pero en
general la selección prescinde de las
jugadoras más jóvenes y con menos
minutos en la absoluta además de She Ila
García quien abandonó hace 10 días tras
no recuperarse de una lesión en abril
España viaja a Nueva Zelanda en el sexto
puesto de la FIFA y con la esperanza de
superar su actuación en la última cita
mundialista en Francia donde cayó
eliminada en octavos contra la campeona
Estados Unidos el 21 de Julio cuando el
equipo debute en la competición contra
Costa Rica será raro ver jugar un
mundial a la roja sin algunas
protagonistas tan importantes como mapi
León o Patrick guijarro